venus pour le repas de midi ap lycée les
honneurs de berry dans l'autre homme
aime entretenir une relation tumultueuse
avec les journalistes de voir que dans
une certaine mesure où ça peut
fonctionner pour lui
est ce que ça peut avoir une influence
sur québec dante
je pense qu'une certaine proximité qu'on
a nous aussi qui est un peu qui est
entré dans les moeurs je pense de la
couverture journalistique de la
politique parce que ça s'est un peu
protégés mais s'il attend toujours une
question vous savez alors on dit tout
oui mais c'est simple et c'est
extrêmement rare d'avoir des emails
épaisse avec un chef de gouvernement à
l'elysée ça arrive jamais les points de
passage sont beaucoup plus formel
est ce que les journalistes au québec
monsieur khouya ont permis aux commandes
rend pas malade
on sait qu'il y avait une certaine
proximité entre les journalistes et les
politiques
mentionner que nous étions à la période
de questions on semble de fait qu'on se
trouve près des fois que face à ce qu'on
ait trop vorace si on veut sortir parce
que moi j'appelle la cassette
c'est à dire les réponses préparées à
l'avancé par des spécialistes des
communications
je pense qu'il faut avoir cette espèce
de voracité peut-être c'est ce que la
beauté d'un os comme c'est d'aller très
rapidement les questions viennent de
partout à la colline parlementaire à
québec on à la ligne verte d'un côté les
politiciens et les journalistes de
l'autre
qu'est ce que ça représente cette ligne
là entre les médias et le pouvoir sa
marque sa marque une limite un espèce de
territoire où on peut pas aller jusqu'à
un certain point à force d'utilisation
s'est rendu compte finalement que la
ligne pouvait nous servir pour
concentrer les points de presse qu'on
fait mais ce qui sera probablement et
pour toujours notre défi la novlangue
terme inventé par george orwell dans son
roman 1984 la définition qu'en donne le
petit robert langage stéréotypes et dans
lequel la réalité est édulcoré ce qu'on
appelle la langue de bois
[Musique]